alors là vous avez le contenu d'une
tablette enseignants les tablettes sont
préparés de différentes manières selon
qu'elles sont remises un enseignant ou
un élève c'est un nouvel outil pour les
établissements scolaires des yvelines le
département déploie en cette rentrée
easy un cartable numérique cent trente
mille élèves et leurs enseignants
essentiellement au collège vont être
progressivement dotés de ce dispositif
le cartable numérique c'est un ensemble
avec un ipad un clavier une coque et des
ressources numériques et un
environnement qui permet donc aux
collégiens de pouvoir travailler
l'enseignant également et donc c'est un
outil qu'il va pouvoir ramener chez lui
donc on travaille en classe sur des
applications et on rentre à la maison
budget pour le conseil départemental
près de 16 millions et demi d'euros pour
un déploiement progressif 21
établissements sont concernés
aujourd'hui en 2026 les élèves des 113
collège des yvelines seront équipés de
cartable numérique à l'oral à l'écrit sa
paire leur permettrait de s'enregistrer
on aura accès à la vidéo également donc
prise de son qui sera simplifié et
surtout de travailler aussi la
différenciation si les enfants ont
besoin d'aller plus lentement dans l'axé
d'un un document par exemple de l'écouté
plus ou de le lire de prendre leur temps
voilà ça ce sera simplifiée puisque
seront tous accès aux documents pour
l'écouter et c'est donc beaucoup plus
simple dans la gestion de classe et
est bénéfique pour le travail des
enfants pour cette nouvelle année
scolaire la collectivité devrait débuter
également son programme de
reconstruction de quinze collèges
énergivores du territoire elle va mener
également des travaux de végétalisation
dans 50 cour de récréation dans les cinq
prochaines années